I guess you have like trust issues with
women or whatnot so I'm like sharing my
location with him just to make him feel
comfortable are you have do you have any
therapy
you need to go back oh my gosh really
you're already trying to make him feel
comfortable two weeks into it it's too
much proving to do you're not his you're
not his wife I'm just being nice and
being like that's not me no it's not no
no it's not being nice it's being a
people pleaser that's not normal you
want to be nice all right let's go out a
couple of times I need you to give you
ten thousand dollars be nice
oh be be nice I mean come on be nice I
mean come on be nice I need ten thousand
dollars and we need to go ahead and run
the Soul Train now be nice no of course
so you so so there are things that sound
crazy to you yeah yeah sharing your
location with somebody you've gone out
with twice is crazy that's just weird I
had to somebody she needed an adult to
say that to her she is an adult first of
all that's some weird [ __ ] that she
needs to be told that and she thinks
it's crazy that's the kind of woman or
that mentality not necessarily that her
but that mentality of um you know
pleasing somebody and giving in to their
whims right away everything they want
just okay just to make keep them happy
is is the beginning of every
relationship that ends in Murder they
all start out real sweet it's it's the
Machiavellian uh you know one one small
step take away one small piece of
Freedom At A Time approach to becoming a
psycho controlling uh relationship
that's [ __ ] up being pretty is not
enough for a lot of man because I'm
pretty and I'm still single so
what do you want
I want a man who's six foot two with two
hundred thousand dollars in the bank and
will treat me like a queen yeah I don't
I I don't know I really don't know what
I want because these men they don't know
what they want a lot of men don't know
what they wanted women you said you're
held again 33
.
so regardless as to what men want you
don't know what you want I mean I know
what I want but what is that
Jasmine first thing I say about ego
they're not willing to be honest be
honest with you I ain't gonna lie I
don't know what I want to do like I've
been screwed and [ __ ] for so long I
don't know what I'm saying just a little
bit of time so it's somebody else's
fault that she doesn't know what she
wants she needs to just sit down and
legit do homework and think about it
anybody that comes along that doesn't
meet that send them back and not married
but I don't want to be good you got
married
yeah you're currently married yes oh
yeah no no no no
mm-hmm
oh you gotta be kidding me bam
were you trolling me
no I'm not a platform with a million
folks actively talking about leaving
your husband to get back with your ex
because he's high value and I look like
no thoughts and the reason you want to
break not gonna want her he's not gonna
want a woman that's willing to cheat on
her husband to be with him if you're a
covenant with God and wreck your home of
the pipefitter guy
is because the previous guy was higher
value meaning he earns more money yeah
yeah social status how he looks what
would the world
say that this woman he got back with is
the one he always wanted she belongs to
the street I don't know how you could go
after a girl that's like that that's
that's horrible well you know it's just
sad that she's sitting there thinking it
was here it was true love he would take
me back that's some fairy tale and it
does happen in fairy tales once in a
while once in one in a trillion times it
happens that way and but in real life
like the odds are not in her paper he's
in a [ __ ] Adam Sandler rom-com where
you find a new partner and then she was
the one on the term motherhood time yeah
you're so right you're getting movies
please
um excuse my French [ __ ] alone they
always want to take me to court yeah it
means that
that break up from when a guy I go
through divorces because they can't take
me leaving them in the dust in the dirt
where I left no matter because they
don't act right so I have to move on is
that right exactly do you think that
that's right of them why are you so why
are you why are you such a poor judge a
character to pick me and you got to
leave
oh damn
no oh damn why are you such a poor jet
no ma'am no ma'am I listen to what you
said you came in talking about how you
feel like you're in divorce court cause
you got to leave these men in the dirt
and all I hear is you're a [ __ ] judge a
character and pick him in because you
don't leave quality men
[Music]
no no God ain't got nothing to do with
it no God ain't got nothing to do don't
bring my God into this God stop giving
me good man that's crazy right she can't
understand her part in it and her
personal responsibility again it's all
just [ __ ] happening to her women didn't
have children anymore and he was unaware
of that so
I like immediately divorced him because
children was the outcome that I wanted
to have it is what it is it is
terrible but but like I told him from
the beginning like I wanted I got
married so we could have children and
then he found out he couldn't have
children after we got married so now I
am actively looking
karma's a [ __ ] how do you know you're
going to be able to carry your children
to turn that's what I I do know that it
is I'm not it it is I'm I'm like I said
so I'm asking seriously man it's not
really a value judgment as much as I'm
just trying to hold the mirror up to you
because you say this [ __ ] the [ __ ] you
say to people around you and they let
you believe this stuff I'm telling you
somebody who got no dog in the fight
that really makes me sad I do hear I'll
hear stories sometimes of people who you
know one partner can't have children the
other one can't and and they they love
each other enough to say well you know
what we'll adopt or we'll do you know
whatever science option there is that
fits us and we're gonna stay together
because I love you and we're gonna you
know find a way to raise children
together I've also heard these stories
or keep trying and then it somehow works
sometimes no well usually when it's not
working for a while people go they get
tested and they'll know like the man has
a lower no sperm count and or the woman
is infertile like they're they're we
have science now on our side yeah
sometimes the science is wrong but for
the most part it really helps people to
understand know what's going on so they
can decide what course of action to take
but to just get up and then leave like
really sad and I've seen and I've heard
stories of men doing that I've heard
stories of women doing that and it just
really says a lot about the the quality
of the love to begin that they had to
begin with yeah I don't really know how
I feel about that to be honest because
like I kind of I guess understand it to
an extent you know what I mean maybe
it's just because I'm I'm young and
naive and I haven't had as much
experience
but um I mean a big point of getting
married and stuff is to have kids so
then if you can't have kids
kind of do want it's it you have to talk
about that stuff before you get married
so you may say the pointless together I
wouldn't even get married anyways okay
let's just say I hear when you would you
should be having a discussion do we want
to have kids yes or no like you know
then then you've got the other people
who are like he didn't want to have kids
but I did and we got married and then he
still didn't want to have kids I thought
once we got married he would and I'm
like well you're a [ __ ] idiot because
he told you flat out what he wanted or
didn't want but assume everybody wants
the same thing I guess I guess you have
to add that extra layer of conversation
what if we can't how are we gonna handle
that
you know before you even get married and
it's hard because there's so many
eventualities like potential situations
you can't figure them all out before you
get married because it'll ruin your
courtship too you're in love
everything's great you're engaged and
you're gonna now you're like what if
your dick doesn't work yeah and you're
like and it's every possible Downer but
to some extent I guess you do have to
talk about it with that a little bit
because that's a big one that's a big
one kids whether or not you want kids
it's best to date not just to have a
relationship you don't have to put a
title on everything together that's what
you need to start telling these people a
title you know I need I need what I need
to do is I need to direct people to this
video and show you what's wrong you
don't need to put a title on nothing it
needs to just be free flowing yeah yep
and over here stuff works where you at
you don't you don't need to put a title
on everything you can have you can have
you can have babies out of wedlock
you'll need to be married you can do
what you want to we're the only
community that operates like this that's
why we gotta take power back for these
mindsets
have you ever opened up something at the
building it came with instructions of
course and it came with parts
of course the way you're talking is you
just start doing [ __ ] you don't need the
instructions you don't need that just
start putting [ __ ] together
you want to live on the fifth floor of a
building like that
got me sweating Kevin I'm gonna
leave I gotta go
call into her show and then all of a
sudden you gotta go when it's when
you're being told you're wrong she God
bless you she thought she was gonna go
in there and teach him something I got
my man's you need to stop putting labels
on
on this and stop trying to put people
teach people how to have a nice marriage
I mean yeah I just what an [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] that sounds bad you're making it
sad yeah it's the truth
I've never seen his show before so it's
obviously it's all single women coming
on looking for advice they all are so
thirsty and trying so hard to look cute
like this one's laying on her stomach
with her phone in bed trying to make
sure like is this is this like a dating
show where then they hope that people
will look at them and well people will
you know start dming them who knows hero
who's a cancer survivor and you're about
to go out and put her off on a not your
mother but your mother's mother oh she's
in her like 80 these right now
I mean I'm I'm happy like you're
actually talking to me about this
because I would never know like if this
is not okay or not what is so goddamn
important that you got to get out to
drop a three-year-old with an 80 year
old
I mean nothing like I was like
trying to go
like blow off steam yeah
yeah wait wait what happened
right gather I don't know I missed the
very beginning but it seems like she was
going to drop her three-year-old off
with an 80 year old family member
who who's got cancer or something and
he's like what's so important that you
gotta leave it your three-year-old with
an 80 year old to watch like could you
imagine Grandma us leaving her with a
three-year-old toddler for more than a
half hour in a case of emergency like
it's extremely exhausting you don't
worry about you don't have to ask the
guy the kind of money he has because the
men you typically date are older and
have money yeah but I think I mean in
general but my point is me and your age
wouldn't have standard chance with you
because they most don't have money
thank you but I'm I mean to each their
own everyone is different I think that
each is each is everybody's different
we're more alike than anything else and
the bottom line is this uh would you
like to be married one day yes okay
um are you going to be submissive
submissive and obedient to your husband
There She Goes you can't make this [ __ ]
up people you make it up
I can't believe I've never met this guy
before and on the OG top G why didn't
you marry the man you chose to have a
child he wasn't good enough for me well
then that should okay so what I need you
to understand on the open dating Market
you come into the open dating Market
with a baby from a man you say wasn't
good enough for you to us to men like
myself to men with good sense that what
says she is a poor judge of character
because she gave a man the highest honor
a woman can give any man on the planet a
child and then she gave a man who wasn't
good enough for her a baby sorry ma'am
don't get upset because I agree with
that but if you agree with it then
understand I agree there's a reason but
I also want to say that I'm allowed to
make Court judgments yes because yeah
you oh yeah you are but you you are
stopped yeah you are but we don't have
but understand something listen listen
listen listen listen listen you are but
the world does not owe you understanding
yo he's right the world doesn't know
they're both right you know she's gonna
grow as a person as she goes on and
unfortunately she made that huge mistake
of having a baby with a loser right a
couple things one this man should be
talking to girls when they're 14. before
they make all these mistakes you know
show the 14 year old girls should be
watching these videos being taught how
to how to be how to act but this girl
you know maybe I didn't we didn't see
the whole video you know her question
should be I made a mistake I have a baby
with with a loser who I knew would not
be good for me to continue to stay with
where do I go from here because that
that's really that's really the problem
like where do I go from here because
he's right she's being judged now
forever as a woman with poor judgment
but maybe she's not that woman anymore
and maybe now she has better judgment
and what what now you know does she have
to be alone forever if she grows and
becomes a better person or more
intelligent thoughtful woman I don't
know thank you guys so much for watching
make sure to like subscribe join the
Discord in my bio uh in the comments so
you can comment videos first to react to
and you can get some of my social media
tips for free
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]